we are coming live from the Euro Village
they're all hot they're giving away
honestly we're so excited Eurovision
Liverpool we went to bed at five o'clock
last night it was a manic and now we're
here at the Village we're performing
here tomorrow we went to the semi-finals
last night and we're going to the finals
tomorrow the thing about is the
countries from all over the world are
here and I know sometimes people think
of the Eurovision we're such a crazy
Doom and Gloom time right now I think
you're even just oh let's all about
Unity it's all about bringing your
people's Unique Style and just seeing a
bit of everything it's like it's like
it's like it's like a selection box it's
not just artists up there performing
songs what they represent and the fact
that laws are coming into like America
and all over the world that are like are
like stopping people from like we're
living in a time where people are so
stuck in their ways and they don't want
change and they're not that open mind
about I feel like the first all to move
forward into the future you got to be
open-minded you got to be open to
everything like move forward not
backwards because like we're in a
totally different world now and it's
scary that things are coming amazing
full stop next question you can see me
hovering desperate to get a word
adventurous will it happen
boys boys boys boys though Ireland
they're not in the final you guys did it
twice what do you think went wrong
honestly you know what Eurovision what
goes wrong it just depends on what the
viewer the job going wrong is they
didn't have jedward but it is very hard
on a band that they didn't get but they
got the table and they should be proud
of themselves though you know a lot of
good acts aren't getting treated fine
you never know what it is I feel like I
think it's like trying to crack a secret
code you know sometimes maybe a song
wasn't right for that year but maybe in
2013 or something it could have been
right but you know you just have to keep
moving forward and trying again but it's
not just so close though didn't yeah
we've got like we're literally lipstick
that year there was such a buzz about
and it's still a classic fans love it
when you when it gets what goes off in
the club they're literally pumped and
we're so happy to be up there we're only
19 years old and like I don't know how
we did it because like it's such an
insane worldwide stage and it literally
propelled us to levels that we never
thought we could reach yeah and it's
great because it's given us something to
celebrate every year when it comes
around were you nervous what will the
acts be going through do you think I
felt like I was from a superhero movie
every time I did it the day-to-day life
is Deadwood though is it yeah when I got
the hair up and I I feel Larger than
Life the thing about the Eurovision is
like mentally and physically you don't
know what your body's going to be like
when you're hearing that countdown
you're ready to go live to like over 200
million people and like it doesn't
matter how much preparing or rehearsals
you do you just don't know what it's
gonna be like on the night but I like to
I feel like we're even in a better place
again if we want to do it for a third
time yeah like we've been through so
much honestly I don't think we'd be
still here today if we hadn't done
Eurovision like we're always consistent
and there's such a I'm not writing a lot
of songs like we're writing real deep
songs about heartbreak and stuff but
then we can write happy songs that are
going the Eurovision pile and like we
rocked Europe club last night twice like
we always Rock our PA so you know if you
want to book jedward get on it like
we're like we're like Olympic athletes
up there you know always wiggling our
hips getting the vibe we love running
she's got lipstick on here I come she's
got a lipstick on it I'm gonna kill the
Vibe by bringing politics into this now
because look we're talking in today
because uh Rishi sunak has now said that
he believes perhaps during Eurovision We
should be hearing from president
zielinski who we think himself did
actually want to speak we know that
Eurovision is politically neutral what
what is your take on that I think Rashid
loser needs to get a grip that's done to
do with him the eurovision's are you
totally different Commodities of the UK
If the fact that the UK are hostinger
for Ukraine and to have the president do
a speech will be so powerful the fact he
just wants to feel included because King
Charles was here so maybe he just wants
to be a part of it because our you know
our leader for tourism well he's not our
leader we're Irish so we're totally like
myself in everyone else's shoes that are
here but it's not it's not so political
it's just a thank you from Ukraine for
for the UK hosting I think people need
to get it just get a grip like Rasheed
get over it like come on you can't be
hanging out with jedward can you on a
sunny afternoon in Liverpool that's what
it's all about absolutely we're enjoying
ourselves
[Music]
oh my goodness Katie we came to you for
Sparkles we came to you for the glitter
you delivered that and more under the
sunshine with the politics I know you
can't get it none of us could get a word
in edgeway but the only way I can get a
word in Edwards is by cutting uh the
mics how can we follow that